should have brought weed yeah yeah I
would have loved that yeah dude he ate
sweet wow I know did they still let you
wear that shirt yeah I know right
I know
I am a poser
yeah I don't smoke I appropriated the
Aesthetics
I should have wore the furry
Birkenstocks that would have completed
the whole thing man summer runs people
are gonna watch this and they're gonna
be projecting themselves onto you and
then you're like he's not a stoner
I feel like I've been lied to
yeah no I mean I smoke a lot
I love tokens
dude I remember because my dad is just
so much older he had me like way later
in life you know I was like ditching
school a lot I was just doing horrible
in school and he goes hey man are you
talking grass and I just started
laughing my ass off and he's like is
this funny to you I'm like dude you just
asked me if I'm token grass that is a
thousand percent funny he was so livid
that I as like horrible as I was doing
in life I still had no amount of
seriousness to like take him seriously
in that moment I know that I'm smoking
weed
[ __ ]
start bullying him I'm micro dosing on
mushrooms
God you don't get it you are so [ __ ]
out of here he wasn't driving I know he
would have smacked the [ __ ] out of me
I like it because I can see how you're
in your face you're still relieved yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's just two hands on the wheel
he damn near kicked me out of the car
that day
anyways dude Guy Fieri's new show
about it yeah hell yeah another bucket
list yeah how was that super cool is it
out or no it's out today
I watched Ron I got fears in your show
guys game nice me it's my good friend
and mortal enemy Bobby Moynihan Bret
Michaels is Ray Michaels is my friend
Carmen Morales and it's a bunch of fun
food based games with Guy Fieri I mean
he is like if Santa Claus is real it's
him I've heard he's the nicest guy in
the world
[Music]
super chill he made the whole thing seem
like you know the big deal for them a
new show launch and he was like I just
don't even matter I'm just doing a thing
you gotta have fun I want promote all
your stuff above and beyond just a real
great guy like everything positive that
you hear about him is a hundred percent
true and like I love that dude he's just
super cool so what kind of games did you
guys play while from weird game you know
like they just take party games and they
take them down you know put a little
spin on them my favorite game we played
was like a hot potato type game where we
had to answer questions and they had
loaded a giant baked potato full of
confetti so if the timer went out and
the potato was in front of you it just
blasted your face it's a real fun time
it was classic television the game show
format people hate but you can't beat it
I feel like game shows in general
they're just they are good you know some
people like a story some people hate a
story but like you can put on a game
show and if it hits right people are
into that oh yeah like decades yeah you
know and I love them I would love like
that that is one of my bucket list
things is the like host a full game show
like Family Feud or Price is Right or
just you know something different and
new either way it matches my temperament
perfectly because I get excited I want
people to win yeah I'm trying to craft
one for YouTube
real prizes you have to do standards and
practices and stuff
no no no no no no no no we're talking
about like the game show like there's
real like game show Cops like if you do
a real game show there that has money
involved there's like game show Cops
that like make sure nobody cheats Nobody
Knows the answers ahead of time it's
free if they have any type of inkling
that your game show is not truly on the
level it'll shut your production down
damn we need to get the game show now to
make it real yeah damn they were on set
for the Guy Fieri thing oh no well the
guy won money no but I did another one
recently I can't talk about yet but
where they were real they were just
making sure that I didn't know the
answers and I didn't you know they yeah
damn did the production have to pay them
to do that yeah what a genius get into
that yeah we got to know the guy who
started that he was like
you need someone here to make sure no
one's cheating right they're like yeah
this is really fun there should be a cop
here yeah
everyone's having a good time
foreign
[Music]
damn no we didn't we didn't have that we
just competed in a game of we put our
pride on the line okay yeah yeah there's
this board game that I play with
Kelsey's family you have a ping pong
ball and a solo cup and like a straw and
like popsicle sticks and they just make
you do different challenges and it's the
funnest board game I've ever played but
is there an actual board no it's not but
it's just little it's like a little
version of a game show how do you play
like who what this oh you have like
points and [ __ ] like that yeah but what
determines how you do the the thing
because you're saying a little board
game it's not a board game it's like
are you sure you don't smoke weed
because this sounds like a very high
game no it's like you're just playing
beer pong really yeah yeah that's what
it was
sorry no what is the flip cup I forget
what it's called dice yeah you roll the
dice yeah and depending what you get it
then it shows you the challenge like the
card will be like all right the
challenge is you have to take the cup in
your mouth and like flip it with your
mouth and have it land okay and if like
you wager so it's like everyone has
little things so you're like you know I
weighed your five points that I can do
this in three tries okay and if you
don't do it then you lose that if you do
it then you got it it's fun for the
whole family yeah yeah I was skeptical
but the more you described it there's
just so many things you can do with like
just supplies like that yeah so many
little games you can play oh is this the
game this is The Game beat that beat
that beat that
yeah kind of an inappropriate name for a
not a family game I think it's it's
funny almost yeah
you got a little bit of everything
involved yeah dude yeah all right I
might play that no I mean coming up with
game show ideas is the number one thing
that I'm always banking like I'm always
just coming up with dumb game show ideas
the last year I was like just this Notes
app list I'm like damn I want to do all
these one day I was gonna ask you to say
something but it sounds serious I don't
want no I mean the one that like my
North Star right now just fight to the
death yeah it's just like casual ideas
okay stuff like that I really want to do
this one I'm gonna call it connect 45
and it's Connect Four on a giant Connect
Four grid but it's 45 pound weights it's
like endurance like infused into like a
just a regular board game okay yeah so
Rogue Fitness if you're watching help me
I thought that could be interesting
because it could be teams you could like
add different challenges of how you're
able to like procure the weight to put
the point in so it could get very
American Ninja Warrior if you want or it
could be connect 45 just 40 normal size
Connect Four board but you have to
connect four to five gigantic and it
would take yeah
you get the 44 and a guy blocks you and
you just start crying
I've been here for three weeks man the
host is like my family has no food
welcome back where's 26 red
[Laughter]
day four of the connect 45 challenge
Cody has 43 red and we're all hoping and
Noel blocks yeah
God damn it
I guess they're gonna start over
the [ __ ] the thing unlocking from the
bottom
just like an infinite range